[Music]
[Applause]
he's ross tucker he's busier than you
are he's the host of the ross tucker
football podcast and uh he was the color
analyst for the raiders browns game last
night on westwood one he'll be going to
the eagles game he'll be doing pregame
for that tonight ahead of washington
versus philadelphia how you feeling
i'm doing fine man it's football season
i got about a month more to uh push
through although i will tell you
yeah i don't often do what i did
yesterday i mean i live in central
pennsylvania the harrisburg hershey area
i drove out to cleveland in the morning
listening to you guys the whole way that
uh mclovin's friend that came up to you
during taps had me rolling uh but let's
see the whole way out
five hours
uh got to the hotel
worked out showered did the game and
then just drove home got home at like 2
a.m last night i didn't feel like
staying over i had too much stuff to do
i don't often do that and i don't often
dan
go to a game
not knowing who was going to play in the
game
i mean i really like like i've heard of
a game time decision before we're now
getting we're in the era of a lab time
decision like i was waiting to hear back
from the lab to see who would be the
starting quarterback for the cleveland
browns three hours before the game
do you think players just don't want to
be tested anymore
like let's just let's just go let's just
you know
we're in the home stretch and who cares
if somebody test positive or got
flu-like symptoms or they're
asymptomatic does the nfl care
well i think there are some players that
do
and those players
had been previously pushing for daily
testing i think the majority of the
players at this point are like you know
what
i'm vaccinated
uh maybe i'm boosting maybe i'm not
you know eighty percent of the guys are
testing positive now are asymptomatic
like we got to play these games
because dan it's kind of crazy right the
game was supposed to be saturday at 4
30.
they postpone it 48 hours
the browns got three guys back
wyatt teller
as well as tack mckinley and john
johnson but they lost jedevian clowney
and they're starting right tackle james
hudson in those 48 hours so the browns
got a net
one more guy dan one more guy so they
moved the whole the nfl moved everything
48 hours
for one extra player
for the cleveland browns i'll tell you
what's really weird now the two things
we got to talk about number one
they're not testing guys
unless you have symptoms well guess what
nobody's gonna say they have symptoms
can you imagine being nfl offensive
lineman
and what your offensive line coaches say
to you if you came in said uh yeah
trainer i have the sniffles i mean they
would look at you like you have three
heads but then i just found out
yesterday i didn't realize this
do you know they're still gonna do some
random testing though
like almost like you're at the airport
and it's tsa pre-check and you go
through and you get buzz and you're like
i don't have any metal on me like oh no
it's just a random they're doing random
which i think dan
presents a real issue like what if next
week they randomly
get a starting quarterback and he's
positive meanwhile the team they're
playing the only guy they randomly test
is the practice squad punter
i i think when you do things randomly
like that it opens you up to criticism
and skepticism about how random it
really is i'm surprised they did that
can you refuse
i don't know is it like when you get
pulled over for a dui or something
you're refusing the breathalyzer
by the way i heard you guys talking
about that yesterday too but my point is
is um
no i don't think you can refuse that's a
great question what what are they going
to do if you do refuse if you do refuse
to they do they say you're a positive or
they find you that's a that's actually
an amazing question
we're talking to ross tucker uh the ross
tucker football podcast um
also uh let's see uh at ross tucker nfl
that's where he is on social media all
right a couple of things let's start
with cleveland how bad are things in
cleveland and how much worse is it going
to get
well i think things are going to get
better in the sense that they'll get a
lot of these guys off the cover list the
problem is their schedule is brutal i
mean everybody in the afc north is
they got to play the packers on
christmas day on saturday now i think
they'll get baker mayfield and some of
these guys back by saturday but
i guess you don't know how long it takes
for the virus to get out of your body so
that you don't test positive
that was a huge loss last night i mean i
i can't remember ever calling a game
there's a lot of things that were
surprising last night but i can't
remember calling a game where if the
team won
they were in first place in their
division
and they were the four seed
but because derek carr led the raiders
for that field goal late
and the browns lost
then they're the twelve seed now they
went from the four seed to the 12 seed
i've never heard of that and it's
because there's about 25 teams in the
nfl that have seven or eight wins right
now it's unbelievable
and you look at the whole afc north they
all have tough schedules moving forward
it kind of feels like the bengals
are the team with the best chance right
now the ravens are kind of reeling
steelers are still kind of beat up the
only thing i thought i knew before the
season
was that the bengals would be the worst
team in the afc north and they might end
up winning the division yeah
yeah i'm just trying to figure out the
cleveland browns if they don't make the
playoffs
have like how do you assess baker
mayfield
for that next big contract that is kind
of hanging over the franchise
i don't think they're going to give him
one
i really don't i mean you know if you
remember after the lions game they won
and he didn't talk to the media the day
after the game and his wife had a social
media post and then even last week
when they beat the ravens
he talked about how they were too
conservative
he talked about internal things
like what are you doing i mean what's he
first of all this is the worst he's
played in a while but secondly
why is he going back to a couple years
ago
when he's saying things in the media
that just don't help the team
internal things calling out the coaching
staff and being too conservative my read
on it
is i think that the contract thing's
bothering him i think that he's seen
what happened with josh allen i think he
probably
has a feeling
that maybe the organization doesn't love
him
and that's got to be hard i mean he's
always had the chip on his shoulder he
walks on a texas tech they don't love
him he leaves he goes to oklahoma it's
got to be tough to be the number one
overall pick
a year ago he's the toast of the town
and the browns are
and i think on some level part of this
build up
is because
he's getting nervous that they're not
they're not going to make him the guy
they're not going to give him the
long-term deal yeah i just wonder what
the browns how they assess this and i
was surprised when he talked about he
talked about something internal and it
felt like there was a disconnect with
him and kevin stefanski the head coach
it it feels like baker's involved in all
of these controversies you know it's
odell beckham it's play calling uh
wanting to play i decide if i'm gonna
play or not and like it just there's a
little too much there for me and not
enough production that i can put up with
this if you give me that and it right
now that's a balancing act that i don't
like
well and and to add on to that okay
they won both of those games
and to me dan as a former player i'm an
offensive lineman
why is he creating drama
after wins
i mean we should be happy we won the
game and yet against the lion they
didn't score very many points or didn't
talk to the media and against the ravens
they let the ravens come back they had
to so he says internal things these are
wins why
that's the part of it that probably
bothers me the most
i was wondering about the job openings
you got the raiders will be open the
bears are open the jags are open
if i gave you
all three to choose from
door number one two or three
um
i think
i think i might go raiders one
and that will surprise people and i took
the raiders too
i think derek carr is a top 10
quarterback in the nfl i mean i i was
impressed by him again last night you
know they dropped a bunch of passes his
o-line's not great they typically can't
run the ball a lick he's been under
pressure forever i think he's i don't
know the eighth ninth tenth best
quarterback in the nfl i'm gonna i'm
gonna go with that right i mean i think
you could say the jaguars entry point is
better because
anything after urban meyer will be a
positive they'll be patient with you you
have trevor lawrence but i'm not
i'm not sure that trevor lawrence is
going to be a top 10 quarterback
i already know that derek carr is
and they were rolling this year until
they had the gruden drama the henry
ruggs accident you know getting rid of
arnett they just had a lot of drama this
year i feel like you get a good coach in
there you stop the drama i think the
raiders could be a playoff team next
year i mean they could be a playoff team
this year still
chris collinsworth brought something up
on sunday night and it's that dirty
secret that if you ask players would you
rather get hit low or get hit in the
head
most players would probably say hit me
in the head i can lose you know i can be
out for a game as opposed to i can be
out for the season like chris godwin if
i ask him today hey would you rather get
hit low or get hit high he's going to
say i'll take the concussion here the
nfl doesn't want to hear this or doesn't
want us to hear this but players feel
this way like okay i got a concussion
if i get a torn acl i'm done
where do you stand on this if i if i
took you back to when you're 26 years of
age and i said hey they can hit you low
or they're going to hit you up high
well um you know a couple things first
of all it doesn't have to be an either
or proposition right i mean you can hit
a guy high
but not be in the head you know you
should the target should be above the
knee to the shoulder i mean need a
shoulder
should be a pretty big target range
but ross let's be fair this is like the
strike zone in baseball where they go oh
it's from the knees to the armpits it's
not it's it's it's far smaller than that
and these defensive players
if you're playing it and it moves so
fast
i i may accidentally hit you and you
don't get fined or suspended i hit you
in the helmet
i get i can get tossed from the game
it's just
they they haven't the
playing field's not level for what a
defensive player is allowed to do
well and to your point dan
if i played defense
i would definitely err on the side of
caution and i would go low yeah i don't
want the fine i don't want the penalty i
would go low and to answer your question
because they've actually changed this
rule as of this year
but when i was playing you get out there
on a screen pass stand or you'd pull out
the outside and there's a corner or a
safety
those guys would come flying up and they
would dive at your knees that's what
they were taught because they can't go
up high if they go up high you're going
to just grab them and throw them so dbs
used to go up my knees i hated that i
would much rather of them come high at
me it hit me in the head i have a huge
head you guys know that i i'd much
rather them hit me in the head than go
low they've actually changed that rule
that outside the tight end box
they can't go low anymore and the dbs
don't really even know what to do
i watched a flag get thrown this weekend
where there was a five-foot tent
defensive back and he had a six-five
lineman and he couldn't do anything he
had to basically say go ahead and and
steamroll me because he couldn't he went
low and he got flagged for that because
there's no other place
like you can't go up top with a lineman
no
no i mean that's just physics that's not
going to work what those guys really
have to do is they gotta just try to
make you miss you know they gotta jab
inside
pop back outside they can't take you on
at all but they used to be taught take
the lineman down right there and create
a pile do you ever get knocked out
never unconscious and in fact
when i played you know i don't really
think we thought it was a concussion
unless you were knocked unconscious i've
seen multiple guys
on the field
asleep like a baby one guy in college at
a night game and one and one time drew
bledsoe we were playing at the
meadowlands
dan he was laying on like the 42-yard
line
like this like like asleep like a baby
and by the way he might have came back
into that game now that i think about it
i'm not even sure just to tell you how
different it was but
i do know in hindsight
several concussions that i got but back
then it was just like
you kind of just saw stars and you're
like oh man that was crazy but you just
kept playing you didn't really know that
that was a concussion and you should say
something and you should come out of the
game uh
most important game for which team
tonight seahawks rams washington eagles
out of those four
who has to win
yeah i would say the eagles i i would
say the eagles you know if the rams win
then they're right there with the
cardinals which is great but if they
lose they're still going to be the five
seed in the nfc
seattle's not going to be able to get
back into it there's too many teams with
seven wins now
for washington i mean as of right now
we'll see what happens at 4 pm but as of
right now they have like 16 18 guys
whatever it is on the covet list eagles
have to win this game i mean the eagles
are coming off of a buy they're playing
against a team has a bunch of guys on
the cobot list including their top two
quarterbacks the eagles if they win then
they're seven and seven right there in
the playoff mix eagles have to win
tonight there's there's no way around it
always great to catch up with you and uh
hopefully you get a breather here next
couple of days
and i will on christmas thank you dan
yeah merry christmas to you buddy and uh
thanks again guys all right that's ross
tucker host of the ross tucker football
podcast he works for cbs westwood one
did the browns raiders last night